وبنشر به تهامه المندوب وروسي في مجلس
الامن الدولي غسيلي نيفيزياء اوكرانيا
اتهامها بتعموت استهداف في المناطق
السكنيه في بومباس باستخدام اسلحه بعيده
المدى وفرها حلف شمال الاطلسي
خلال جلسه غير رسمي لمجلس الامن الدولي
نظمتها روسيا بشان الاوضاعف
شنته اكثر من الف هجوم واسع النطاق على
دوم بس منذ اواخر نوفمبر الماضي
من دول النيترو في صيف 2020 كسب النظام
كيف فرصا جديدا لتدمير مدن باس بطريقه
مستهدفه ومتعمده ومنذ ذلك الحين تم
الابلاغ عن زياده بمقدار اربعه اضعاف في
الخسائر بين المدنيين وحدثت زياده بمقدار
ثلاثه اضعاف في تدمير البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه منذ اواخر نوفمبر تم الابلاغ عن
اكثر من 2000 حاله من الهجمات واسعه
النطاق وتتعرض بدون نت لها هجمات اليوميه
تسفر عن مقتل العشرات من المدنيين في وسط
المدينه ومناطقها الاداريه والسكنيه